he's not going to be able to escape deaf
and he's pissed off about it
the angels sitting around and maybe
they'll be god they're so angry about it
me too
i'm furious about it me too i'm telling
you can't we do something no but that's
why you and i
are so much alive i know we want to be
we want to be the only ones that live
forever
i mean especially i think when you have
a life like we have yes
and then one day it's over i mean that
really pisses me off governor where are
we going to go when we die
be honest with us
how you guys doing if you haven't
subscribed already hit that notification
bell subscribe right now so you can get
the latest dean show
sent to you and support us on our
patreon page
now somebody shared this next clip and
they wanted me
to go ahead and do a reaction to it
starring none other than arnold
schwarzenegger in such
films as predator and terminator
you guys know the rest of them probably
better to me arnold schwarzenegger also
former governor of california
and tv radio
tv personality howard stern they talk
about one of the
topics that actually
keeps us awake believe it or not you got
usually two and you'll see what happens
here
as we react to this as i react to this
people end up usually
making a joke about it turning away from
it
but we actually as muslims we like
discussing it
because it gives us hope it's not
something that we look as
being pessimistic but there is great
optimism
in the topic of death and hopefully
you'll get to benefit from this also
let's go ahead and react to this
video and hopefully inshallah god
willing this can also get to our friends
arnold
schwarzenegger and howard stern
let's go ahead are you afraid of them
are you informative no i'm not afraid of
death i am just
pissed off about it yes because i mean
especially i think when you have a life
like we have
yes and then one day it's over i mean
that
really pisses me off governor where are
we going to go when we die
i mean who loves deaf i mean there's a
statement from
prophet muhammed's wife she actually
talks about this like
because the one who loves to meet his
creator
allah god almighty loves to meet that
individual but she
had mentioned like but people hate death
how can you reconcile with this
because the moment of death is where you
depart
from your family like there's another
beautiful statement by the last and
final message muhammad peace and
blessings be upon
him where he talks about when the when
the person leaves that's anybody arnold
schwarzenegger
howard stern when you leave this life
there's a few things that
depart with you one of them is your
family
and your wealth and your deeds what you
did in this life
so what goes with you are not the
fancy cars the airplanes the clothes the
jewelry none of that stuff goes with you
and your family can't go with you they
actually stay behind
and then what happens they end up
fighting over the material possessions
but what you did in this life
arnold what you did in this life howard
stern that is what carries on to the
next life
and then going back to the other
statement that we were
what i was talking about is that when a
person is given the glad tidings
of paradise then they're happy now
now that sadness that followed them that
pain
of departing because death does have its
pains there's pains of death if we call
it
separating it disattaching from this
life can be
it's very very painful but now when the
angels come to you
and they give you the glad tidings of
what you prepared you build you planted
seeds of goodness in this life
and now you lived your purpose your true
purpose in life according to god's will
not your desires
now what happens is you get that glad
tiding
of paradise and now the joy overtakes
you because now the mercy of god is
coming let's continue on
here as we react to this arnold
schwarzenegger and howard stern
video be honest with us well the truth
is that you got six feet down there
that's gonna rot there yes absolutely
that's it i thought you were
told me to be uplifting what did i say i
said usually see
howard stern is asking a good question
like where are we going to go when we
die
and then arnold tells the truth you're
going to rot
you're going to be worm buffet worm food
in the grave all of us muslim non-muslim
christian jew it doesn't matter
that body that you lived in this vehicle
that's supposed to get you through this
life
now it's temporal it's temporary now
it's going to go ahead
and it's going to be put in the grave
and it's gonna rot he's right
and then what happens people as i said
they start laughing you can see i
believe this is one of the
nighttime tv talk show hosts he's
laughing i mean there
it just becomes a big joke but people
know deep down inside
howard stern he's for real he also he's
like
i'm scared it scares me let's continue
on
hopefully there is a life after this and
we all
know it's going to be different if
there's a life after this not hopefully
but definitely
hundred percent 110 more than i'm
actually you're looking at me
here that reality that you're watching
us here right now
no there's a greater reality because
this is temporary
but the truth of the matter is without a
shadow of the of a doubt
that there is a life after here after
here
there yes there is a life after the
hereafter
100 percent i hope there is life
it's not going to be like this i'm not
going to sit after we are dead we're not
going to sit here like this
and do interviews and have a great time
and have laughs and have robin there you
know giving us this
beautiful smile all the time either no i
mean this will be
different maybe there will be angels
sitting around
maybe they'll be god they're smacking us
every time we say something afforded the
word or something like that right
i mean they'll say [ __ ] there's a
whatever i mean i don't know what it is
but
it is upsetting and i cannot stand it
are you angry about it i'm so angry
about it me too i'm
furious about it me too i'm telling you
can't we do something no but that's why
you and i
are so much alive i know i don't want to
be we want to be the only ones that live
forever
there's a few points here earlier he
said in the video he talked about
especially he's pissed off arnold
schwarzenegger is pissed off
i mean you who wouldn't be upset when
you have like
the lavish lifestyle i mean come on
arnold schwarzenegger i mean this guy's
got paradise on earth
so it's going to come to an end so now
it's kicking in because he's getting
older
and for those people out there who are
thinking like many of us
get fooled people get fooled they think
like okay they're going to develop
science
is going to come up with something and
we're going to be able to take this pill
and it's going to reverse our aging and
we're going to be able to expand our
life
if anybody was able to do that with all
their money prestige and
all their fame and all the connections
they have arnold schwarzenegger would
have been able to do that but you can
see
arnold schwarzenegger is definitely
getting up in age
and he's very healthy he's very fit and
deaf he's not going to be able to escape
deaf and he's pissed off about it
pissed off and then he talks about
especially the kind of life that we
lived
there's another statement by the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
now remember if you believe in prophet
muhammad is the last and final messenger
and i really i really humbly
request arnold schwarzenegger howard
stern these people to sincerely take a
look
at anybody out there they're not yet
muslims to take a look
be genuine not disingenuous and look
into his life look into the life of
prophet muhammed peace and blessings
be upon him who michael h hart he's a
famous historian
he put he wrote a book the hundred most
influential men in history
and he put look he was not muslim he put
prophet muhammad as number one most
influential man
in history doesn't it make sense
that you would study you studied all
these other people's
lives but why not study the life of
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
who came with a simple message that you
worship the creator not the creation
he confirmed jesus moses abraham and all
the other messengers that came
with the same message believe in one and
only one god
no buts after that meaning it doesn't
turn into a trinity
i mean this is what what people go a lot
most of the time away from
man-made religions because they don't
make sense they don't fit with the
natural disposition that we have to
believe in one and only one god
and that belief now should manifest some
actions
that actions of good morality of good
conduct and those are those seeds of
goodness that you plant in this life so
you can go ahead they can be
transferable into the next now
there's a statement by prophet muhammad
peace and blessing be upon him as there
are many gems of wisdom
teachings for us because he was a
teacher teaching us how to get to
paradise how to worship god the same way
if you were living there in the time of
jesus
you'd have to obey him not worship jesus
as a god next to god i said my god damn
my god
no because jesus peace be upon him who
was worshipped right before jesus came
on the scene
who are people worshiping think about
that one who are people worshiping
right before he came on the scene they
were worshiping the god jesus called
people to worship
who was his mother think about that one
who was his mother when he was in the
womb when jesus was
in the womb of mary peace maryam mary
peace
and blessings be upon her who was she
worshiping who was she praising
she was praising the creator of the
heavens and earth the one and only one
god almighty
in arabic we say allah in aramaic allah
this is the one god so now you can see
the consistency the chain of revelations
you can see
moses brought the same message worship
one and only one god
don't set up partners next to god and
obey the messengers that was sent moses
at his time abraham at his time
and they all brought the glad tidings
they brought they brought the purpose of
life to the people
how they can seek forgiveness from god
what their duty responsibilities in this
life
were and at their time they were given
the revelation
but now at this time arnold
schwarzenegger's time now
because he's on earth howard stern's
time
and the other late night show guy
for them that messenger is prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
so i i really sincerely i really
sincerely humbly ask you to look into
his life
and he said a dunya
what does that mean that means this life
is like a jail for the believer an
agenda a paradise for the disbeliever
think about that one wow and that goes
back to what
arnold schwarzenegger he was saying
especially i think when you have a life
like we have
especially the kind of life that we were
living can you imagine
what men loved most and he had all that
what food he liked
he had all that the cars he liked he had
all that
he was at the top of the top there's no
more getting to the top
arnold schwarzenegger he had all the
finer things in this life
and now it's coming to an end so imagine
of course he's going to be pissed off
he's going to be pissed off and then for
the believer we have certain limits
certain restraints
we can't be going to the nightclub
drinking alcohol
fornicating but god made processions
here
he gave us for a man he can have up to
four
a woman now also inside of marriage she
is somebody who is a mother
she is someone who raises the future
nations she's also someone who's
elevated
to a whole another level in islam she's
got her roles and responsibilities the
husband's got his roles and
responsibilities
we have a purpose in this life and
everything is laid out
beautifully perfectly so this world can
function better society can function
better homes can function better
families can function better and that's
how you can get peace
when you come into the house of peace
islam submission to the creator
peacefully in obedience and submission
not to his creation
and that's how you get the blueprint for
life contentment and peace in this life
the tools
to handle many of the challenges that
come because we're going to be tested we
know that this life is a test
but then you cross over and it's not the
pessimism that
comes with when you talk about death
that's why people run away
from this topic and that goes back in
the video like
howard stern's like i'm scared i'm
scared of death what did he say
and the other guy late night show guy
he's laughing and they're laughing it's
like a joke and
no it's a serious matter just think
about it go in the dark one day nobody's
around
and just close your eyes close your eyes
and think when you're going to be put in
the grave
you got a big enough backyard arnold
schwarzenegger howard stern
you guys got some land dig up a hole
just try it as an experiment
you don't have to go six feet under
maybe just three feet under just lay
there cover yourself with a blanket
in the dark think about it you don't
just go to sleep that's wishful thinking
thinking that it's just going to be okay
it's like going to an auction
and there's a car that's worth 50 000
dollars you think oh i'm gonna bid five
thousand i'll get it that's wishful
thinking you have less of a chance not
doing nothing
not seeking the truth the signs come to
you just like this a sign is coming to
you
and you reject it you had all that time
to seek out the purpose of life to ask
your creator sincerely humbly
the one who created me guide me guide me
what do you want from me in this life
and help me to fulfill it
you didn't do any of that and you know
for every individual
there are certain signs that the creator
sends and then there are the greater
signs and the greatest signs that we
have
today this day is the quran and the life
of prophet muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him and you owe it to yourself
to look as this message comes to you god
willing inshallah
that you look into the life of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
with an open mind
and then you go ahead and read the quran
read the quran
ask your question look at the
fundamental belief system in islam
be genuine sincere with a humble earnest
desire to really want to know the truth
and then you will find in no
other way of life other than islam
the complete the details of what happens
in this scenario when you leave when you
transfer over from this life
to the next what happens all the details
of the day of judgment all the criminals
will be
brought forth everyone will have to be
accountable
for what they did and then the ultimate
reward of jannah
a paradise this is what jesus taught the
pure monotheism
and doing good deeds being a righteous
human being you'll falter you'll fall
but then you turn back to the creator of
the heavens and earth
the all-loving the most kind the most
merciful and you ask
directly not through a middleman
intermediary just
to god almighty the creator allah alone
you ask for forgiveness
and he will forgive he forgives all sins
except setting up rivals partners with
him even if you were doing that
but before you die you repent he will
forgive and then change your bad deeds
into good deeds what a beautiful barter
why would you not look into this a
little bit further
and that's my humble advice and my
reaction to that i can go on but we'll
cut it short right here
thank you guys for tuning in do that i
left you with three things arnold
and howard is one to be genuine and
sincere
and to look into the life of prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
not from the haters
of islam but code of the islamic sources
hook up with a muslim a knowledgeable
muslim
i'm sure you got some friends and hear
what he has to say
ask the tough questions two is read the
quran
you owe it to yourself you owe it to
yourself you've read so many other books
read the quran clear quran.com is a
great translation you also have sahih
international
don't just go again for someone who's
translated and given a bad translation
many of these orientalists who are on
the
attack get a really good translation of
the quran
and then three ask the creator of the
heavens nerf to guide you be sincere in
it
and then you will have all of the
resources to get you through this life
and god willing to get you into the
paradise into the next
i hope mr arnold howard and the late
night
talk show guy this has been a benefit
and everybody else who's listening to
and watching and who really wants to
know why have i been created why am i
here
you have everything laid out in islam
just be sincere
don't be disingenuous be genuine and
sincere
and humble yourself and ask your creator
the one who created this whole universe
and everything in it to guide you to the
truth and then look into this beautiful
way of life subscribe right now
if you didn't do in the beginning hit
the notification bell support us on our
patreon page
we'll see you next time inshallah god
willing here on the dean show
peace be with you assalamu alaikum